the jurgen experience i keep hearing
there's a formula shortage which is
terrible oh the baby formula yeah i saw
that recently where's
how is that what's going on
what's going on there um
i don't know how the [ __ ] do you not
have enough baby flying
i'm happy they don't first of all what
because
and i'll tell you why please do
baby formula ain't no good for babies
it's not
not most most of them are not but some
women can't pump
someone's right right right for whatever
reason they're milk ducks absolutely
absolutely and there's alternative
formulas out there like there's really
good um some of them are like soy based
i'm like i don't get your childhood
but like when you talk about i don't
want to name companies because that
could give me legal issues right but
the formula that's on the market has a
lot of toxic ingredients in it and ain't
good for babies like what what kind of
toxic ingredients i don't know i haven't
studied this stuff in years but let
people do their own research right and
let people go and there's a lot of
people that have done this research
let's see if we can find it see find out
what what's bad about baby formula pull
up the ingredients just just google
what's bad about baby formula
okay you might have to use those it
might be a thank you an alternative yeah
that would give you bad would you say
that would give you bad blog results
like that's going to give you oh goofy
[ __ ] that people are trying to sell
stuff how about toxic ingredients in
baby formula
google that
that might work would that work
what are you doing over there jimmy you
wrestling with that microphone
[Laughter]
um but i don't know you know like it's
definitely better to have breast milk
yes absolutely i think for some women
that's
uh an impossibility right so then all
right maybe you got a headache
that formula right
but um i think
a lot of women um
also can't afford the breast milk
because the breast movement is expensive
you know if you can't nurse oh you mean
buying breasts yeah yeah it's very
expensive yeah that stuff is very
expensive so it's hard to get
alternatives
and the thing is like there are people
that are making
um baby formula that is like
organic holistic
but because of
like fda regulations there's certain
guidelines that got to stay within so
they can't say oh this is safe for a
newborn right oh but you can
technically give it to a newborn but
they can't put that on the label and say
hey this is good for a newborn you can
get this stuff on amazon right
um
but there's organic like good baby
formula out there so they can't call it
baby formula is that what it is yeah
well what are they it's like it's more
they they stay they uh market it towards
like more toddlers
huh so like it's it's like uh i want to
say
6 to 12 months or 12 months to 24 months
or something like that yeah i just had a
baby so that's why i was
like yeah all in it well here it is
some of america's biggest manufacturers
baby food have not been adequately
testing and removing products with
dangerous levels of heavy metals
according to new congressional u.s
congressional report this is all part of
an ongoing battle to make baby food safe
the new report says gerber and beechnut
didn't properly test and remove these
products while sprout foods incorporated
walmart's parent choice and plum
organics were relaxed in their efforts
arsenic lead cadmium and mercury were
found in rice cereals sweet potato
purees
juices and sweet snack puffs according
to a previous report from the
subcommittee on economic and consumer
policy committee on oversight at the
time the companies nature sells happy
family organics and happy baby products
beechnut hayne earth's best organic and
gerber agreed to the subcommittee's
previous request for investigation the
subcommittee also reached out to walmart
campbell and sprout organic foods which
did not allow the investigation those
companies later began cooperating
yeah that's what i was talking about so
there's a toxic baby food lawsuit cases
for parents at the bottom there
interesting yeah
um and then so then you see the adhd
autism situation popping up because of
the heavy metals neurotoxins yeah right
for parents who have bought food from
any of the brands and have children with
autism and attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder both autism and
adhd have been associated with toxic
metals
yeah so when you when i saw that i saw
this story pop up so in the back of my
mind i'm like good
right it's like it's like in some ways
it's bad because the baby needs
something right it needs something right
but in another way i'm just like you
know it's it's catch 22. why is there a
shortage
why is there a baby food shortage
yeah i thought it was because of um is
it the putin price hike
i thought it was because the um here it
goes
wow look at that 40 of baby formula out
of stock thread on inf uh infant formula
shortage situation which feels like a
slow moving train wreck
first retail stock has been rocky for
months it was already bad over the
holidays then a big recall plus plant
shutdown in february made it worse
oh so there's a plant shut down oh
that's right because the plants have
been burning down
you saw that yeah it did that was like
food production plans yes you processed
it yeah why is that why is that
happening
man if it's a good time to be a
conspiracy theorist it's a great spot
because you know you got a lot of
[ __ ] ammunition yeah i i i
i tend not to look into this stuff
it's probably because it gives me
anxiety yeah it gives me anxiety too
that's why i need weed
mark typhoon weed
[Laughter]
they say abbott nutrition recalled with
the
contamination after
i'll hit it that's the bike tyson wheat
oh man it's dangerous oh boy
possible contamination of several
infants got sick and infants got sick
and two died whoa
abbott nutrition recalled and withheld
some of its baby formula product due to
concerns about possible contamination
[ __ ]
all this stuff is terrifying man
just when you hear stock talk about you
know um
about food shortages to keep saying food
shortages are coming yeah and people are
saying food shortages are coming i'm
like what
do something yeah how do you know it's
coming
where's the food coming from